we are taking your calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 we are going to go to our next
caller from the five-one-six-- area code
caller tell us who you are where you're
calling from and what what question you
have today ok um I'm from Dalton New
York my name is Monique and my question
I'm not even sure if I could call a
question Buffalo on Orthodox it's my
observation that sometimes Democrats and
concerns and Democrats and problems they
talk past each other in the sense that
Republicans aren't interested in the 23
million people that might lose health
insurance and so much that they're more
interested in how it would affect them
so I was thinking it would be a little
more efficient or it would actually get
their attention if everything was framed
in a way that would show them how it
would directly affect them for instance
yeah like I think I understand what
you're saying like if I can jump in jump
in and give my thoughts on that because
there's sort of a lot there and I think
if we go further we might there's
already a lot to discuss there I've been
arguing for a while that when
progressive progressives want to make
inroads probably not with Republican
lawmakers but maybe with moderate and
conservative voters you need to start
talking about the issues that are
important to us in terms that will
resonate with them George Lakoff has
talked about this when it comes to
framing when we talk about health care
it needs to be talked as a patriotic
duty to make sure that at least some
basic level of care is afforded to all
and I would add we can also talk about
how it will hit the
our checkbooks when people are uninsured
and use the emergency room as primary
care when we talk about the environment
and climate change we need to be talking
not about science and 97 or 98% of
scientists believe this in that although
that's true because if they haven't been
convinced by that already they're not
going to be convinced by that we need to
be talking about the moral and ethical
duty that exists the nationalistic
opportunity for the United States to
take the lead on the future of
technology there are other ways to frame
these issues to appeal to the right and
I I think you're absolutely right about
that Thanks all right very good great in
my reply Monique in New York very very
much appreciated